so this is National reading month and a
new documentary is bringing attention to
why children in this country are
struggling to learn to read how is this
possible according to the National
assessment of educational progress only
33 percent of fourth grade children 33
percent fourth grade children were
reading at proficient levels in 2022 the
right to read follows an activist a
first grade teacher and two families in
their fight to teach their students and
children to read Kareem Weaver the NAACP
activist in Oakland argues that literacy
is one of the great civil rights issues
of our time
illiteracy is the pipeline of prison
it's also the pipeline of homelessness
is the pipeline to unemployment and
depression
in our publishing companies that sell
popular curriculum that do not teach our
children to read making millions of
dollars
from the day I set foot in Oakland I
realized that everything starts with
literacy everything starts with reading
science math history you name it if you
can't read you can't access anything
else
LeVar Burton former host of Reading
Rainbow is one of the movie's executive
producers he knows a thing or two about
reading he is here with the director of
the great Jenny McKenzie who is also
Behind movies like kick like a girl and
the emmy-winning quiet Heroes we welcome
you both to the table this documentary
guys is so good and I learned so much
watching it I find it so hard to believe
in 2023 kids who are going to school
LeBar still can't read that's true why
is that how is that possible we have
failed them in America in our school
systems we have we have failed them by
not giving them evidence-based reading
instruction what does that mean well
they're being taught yes we went on a
tangent with whole language learning
which is to say you you teach children
to sort of memorize right pictures uh
and divine meeting from from what they
see on the page in terms of the images
not the letters phonics got abandoned
and and and everything went downhill
from there I know Jenny there's a very
powerful scene in the documentary where
you see this little girl reading what
she's doing is translating the pictures
when they showed her the words she could
not read them exactly Gail it's we
naturally learned to speak but reading
is a complicated task and the Brain
isn't naturally wired to learn how to
read so we have to learn with systematic
explicit instruction it's great to
expose kids to books but it's not the
same as teaching them how to read so
Jenny they're companies that are making
money off of programs that are not
actually teaching kids how to read how
did that happen
I think it happened because we have
truly prioritized profits and politics
over outcomes for our children so it's
shocking I mean when we think that 37 of
children in this country are reading
below a proficient level sorry below
basic not proficient I can't read it
truly does Tony it means they cannot
read and to create a third of our
children who are illiterate is
catastrophic I mean it's something we
should all be screaming about it's a
compound problem it is absolutely Levar
in the documentary we meet a first grade
teacher who understands this problem and
goes against her District's own
curriculum to devise a plan that works
he's a hero like and like many teachers
they are really caught in a bind they
want to do the best they can for our
children but they are constrained by
school districts and public policy and
we just we have to do better it affects
more kids of color why guys
because I know a big sigh yeah because
our kids get less always especially when
it comes to education and and and in
this country there is a certain
population who can afford that
additional extra instruction tutors yeah
and the like most low-income people not
all low-income people just can't afford
that luxury but you both say this is
fixable very much so invincible and not
hard to fix we have the research we have
the data and we need to take that
research and data and implement it into
practice I mean what does that think
about we have the research day what what
specifically needs to be done what needs
to be done Gail is we have to have
evidence-based research curriculum for
kids to learn to read that is tested for
kids across all demographics I mean
leaving children who are poor and
children who are black and brown behind
is not a new problem we have been facing
these kind of inequality issues for
years so we have to test reading
instruction with all kids across the
country it's all because of the way the
kids are taught yeah I'm flipping around
absolutely I have to say here that some
of the Nations uh literacy program
leaders the most popular programs and
we're not naming them for for uh on
purpose they say that they stand by
their methods and that their work is
being mischaracterized yeah well that's
not your response that's that's not true
the work is not being mischaracterized
they're lying to protect their bottom
line this is America say it's about
money it is in part not everything is
about money but this is a big part of
this equation
but how are schools and teachers allowed
to get away with it you said literacy
starts at home with parents but really
it's you said it really falls on the
schools does it not
it definitely falls on leaders and
policy makers but change has to begin
with us and I think right now we are a
part of a movement that is being talked
about which is really the early literacy
crisis and people need to ask questions
they need to talk to their District
leaders they need to talk to their
principals and say how are you teaching
reading that's what Karen should ask
that's the question parents should ask
how are you teaching my child how to
read
how are you teaching all right thank you
for coming and LeVar Burton is on record
he said if he would like to be here if
jurika wins
our Burton coming for you he wants to
see durika get slimed yikes
McKenzie thank you thank you both thank
you celebration of read Across America
day and National reading month the right
to read will be available for free to
all audiences for one week beginning
today you can register at the right to
read film.org